right now we get to the news we do have
some breaking news from South Texas
where the FBI says four American
citizens have been assaulted and
kidnapped just over the Border in Mexico
these photos are believed to show the
kidnapping which began with a volley of
gunfire Christina raffini is in
Washington with the latest Christina
good morning
good morning Vlad the FBI says our men
took the four Americans shortly after
they crossed the border into Mexico and
this video posted online appears to show
some of them may be injured a warning
some of the images in this report are
disturbing
a post on Twitter Friday appears to show
the moment four Americans were kidnapped
in Mexico one woman walking on her own
was forced into a white pickup truck men
armed with long guns and wearing
bulletproof vests are then seen dragging
one person after another into the
vehicle this happened Friday in
Matamoros Mexico it's a Border Town
that's only about a 12 minute drive from
Brownsville Texas the FBI says the four
Americans entered Mexico driving a white
minivan with North Carolina license
plates shortly after crossing the border
gunman opened fire on the passengers in
the vehicle all four Americans were
taken from the scene by the attackers
their conditions are unknown also on
Friday the U.S embassy in Mexico posted
an alert about media reports of an
individual shot during what appears to
be the same incident warning government
employees to steer clear the alert also
reminds U.S citizens that this
particular part of Mexico is a level
four do not travel the highest level
warning in the state Department's travel
advisory system the Consulate in
Matamoros has posted at least four
security alerts since February of 2020.
warning of drug cartel violence crime
kidnappings and clashes involving
criminal armed groups
the FBI is offering a fifty thousand
dollar reward for the return of the
victims and the arrest of those involved
Tony
so a lot of questions but doesn't look
good Christina thank you very much